sí muy buenos días pues este es un
anuncio que va a hacer el presidente de
manuela este miércoles siendo que
efectivamente debería darse ese cambio a
partir del mes de julio de 2021 pasando
de 14 a 28 días porque a este cambio
bueno hubo un reporte entregado por una
comisión de expertos en infancia que fue
entregado al gobierno nacional a
comienzos de este mes y éste vino a
sumarse también a otras voces que desde
hace tiempo venían pidiendo que se
ampliará aún más la licencia de
paternidad en ese reporte pues dicen la
importancia de la relación entre padre e
hijo que debe comenzar desde el
nacimiento y que además va a tener unas
implicaciones a largo plazo en la vida
del individuo que es lo que va a cambiar
pues básicamente llega a 28 días tres de
esos días son costeados por el empleador
algo que ya es el caso pero lo que
cambia es que los 25 siguientes días si
serán costeados por la seguridad social
esto está estimado que va a costar al
menos unos 500 millones de euros a la
seguridad social
lo que cambia también en esto es que el
gobierno quiere que una parte de esa
licencia sea obligatoria porque en este
reporte entregado por los expertos se
dieron cuenta que el 70% de los padres
no se toman está solamente el 70% pero
no se toman esta licencia el resto no lo
hacen esto tiene también que ver con el
tipo de contrato que tenga la persona si
está en una situación precaria o no
entonces quieren de alguna manera pues
el limitar estas desigualdades en el
país y en la sociedad mentalidad de
cambio de tema porque se espera que en
las próximas horas se den a conocer las
conclusiones de la reunión no del
consejo de defensa sanitaria que convocó
el presidente emmanuel mccrone respecto
de nuevas medidas para contener un nuevo
avance de coronavirus se sabe algo al
respecto
bueno lo que se sabe es que será olivia
de ago el ministro de salud quien de
nuevas declaraciones a las 7 de la noche
hora local él todos los días dará como
este este este punto de resumen de cómo
está la situación de la pandemia en el
país pero lo que se espera es que
durante ese punto s cuando se dirija la
prensa el día de hoy hablé sobre nuevas
restricciones que tendrán el lugar aquí
en parís porque este lunes hubo una
reunión entre la alcaldesa de parís la
agencia regional de salud de isla de
francia que es el departamento que
albergará la capital y también en la
prefecto de policía así que se esperan
nuevas restricciones entre ellas que se
no se venda más alcohol por ejemplo a
partir de las 8 de la noche y menos de
reuniones de menos de 10 personas habrá
que esperar esta noche para saber cuál
es el alcance total de todas estas
medidas muchísimas gracias natalia ríos
por este completísimo reporte desde la
capital francesa